morning all the government is facing
calls for an inquiry after a former
conservative minister claims she was
sacked from her role
after party whips said her muslim faith
was making colleagues uncomfortable in
an interview with the sunday times the
mp nusrat ghani says she was told in
early 2020 her muslimness was raised as
an issue at a meeting in downing street
however the government chief whip mark
spencer has branded her claims
completely false and defamatory
well in an interview with the sunday
times the mp said this it was like being
punched in the stomach
i felt humiliated and powerless
she continues i will not pretend that
this hasn't shaken my faith in the party
but in response the chief whip took to
twitter last night
these accusations are completely false
says mark spencer and i consider them to
be defamatory i have never used those
words attributed to me
it is disappointing when this issue was
raised before ms ghani declined to refer
the matter to the conservative party for
a formal investigation at more of the
detail now from our political
correspondent rob paul
nuzrat ghani made history in 2018 when
she was the first female muslim minister
to speak from the dispatch box the front
bench position where the prime minister
speaks from mpmq's now she was cheered
when she
did that but now in an interview with
the sunday time she says that when she
was sacked from that ministerial
position in the department for transport
she was told that part of the reason why
she was sacked was because some
people were uncomfortable with what she
said was termed her muslim woman
minister status um
and that part of the reason as well was
that she was uh hadn't been loyal enough
to the conservative party
and not defended them against
islamophobia accusations she said she
was told this
by a government whip of course the whips
are the enforcers that are responsible
essentially for party discipline now in
a pretty rare intervention because you
rarely hear from
whips on the record
anyway the chief whip who's essentially
in charge of the team of enforcers mark
spencer issued a public
denial last night
but also identified himself as the
person that nus
was referring to he said in a series of
tweets which were initially deleted but
then re-published
to ensure other whips are not drawn into
this matter i'm identifying myself as
the person nuzrat ghani mp has made
claims about this evening these
accusations are completely false and i
consider them to be defamatory i have
never used those words attributed to me
it is disappointing that when this issue
was raised before ms ghani declined to
refer the matter to the conservative
party for a formal investigation now
nusrat ghani says in this interview with
the sunday times the reason why she
hasn't
raised this sooner was because at the
time she was told that if she did she'd
be ostracized by colleagues and also
have a career and a reputation destroyed
what we have seen
is concern coming really from across the
political spectrum the education
secretary nadim zahawi
said there is no place for islamophobia
within the conservative party and has
called for an investigation we've heard
from a chief whip former chief whip mark
harper that says there should be an
inquiry also the labour party asking for
downing street and the conservative
party uh to open an investigation um as
well and william rag that tory mp that's
meeting the police next week about
accusations of blackmail says that the
party really needs to do better
so very very serious accusations landing
at the government's door amid the real
swirling uh drama of the partygate
scandal and the sue gray report which we
now understand will probably not be
published tomorrow and will come
slightly later
in the week so a difficult week
for boris johnson on many fronts
clearly another bruising week for boris
johnson he has
thus far managed to avoid that vote of
no confidence but the findings of sue
grey's investigation into daring street
parties well that's just around the
corner uh well let's get a little more
on the mounting pressure the pm finds
himself under and we're joined now by
former dining street adviser mo hussein
well great to see you this morning um
i wonder if we might start with those
latest allegations and i don't think
there's any need for us to speak in any
kind of depth about them given that the
chief whippers has denied them but just
speaking in general terms how bruising
how rough can the whipping process be
it can be quite it can be quite
difficult it's always going to be about
carrots and sticks because your job as a
whip is trying to make sure the mps
delivered the government's promises and
commitments and they honored the
manifesto commitments that they
themselves stood on as mps so often
whips will use things like promises of
government jobs or perhaps the minister
will go and visit your constituency at
some point uh or you might get some
funding for an election campaign uh in
your in your in your patch as well so
that i think has been part of the course
these allegations that we're hearing are
much more serious and i think do warrant
investigation because whip should not be
promising things like taxpayers funds uh
for
things in various parts of the country
or not that's for the government to do
not for the whips that has to go through
due process
yeah i don't mean just just on that
topic i mean it does feel well i've been
speaking to a few old westminster hands
over the past couple of days and they're
saying look come on it's always been
like this there's always been a strong
arm tactic but it does rather feel that
in promising or withholding promises
promised money you know making direct
threats you know there has a line may
well have been crossed and putting this
stuff into the public domain that makes
it far less likely it can ever happen
again
yeah exactly and it's a real breakdown
of trust that we're now seeing between
the whips and some back benches and i
think this is part of the problem the
the the 80 seat majority as as great as
that was and has been is a double-edged
sword because the more back ventures you
have to almost corral and look after
they're not all going to get government
jobs because they there aren't enough
jobs so you can't promise all of them
something and there's always going to be
some people who uh feel that they
probably once they've rebelled once can
rebel again so it is it is a challenge
but there are limits to what the whip
should be certainly using and saying and
doing
um all eyes though remain on sugree and
uh whenever that report may ultimately
be produced it does again feel like over
the past couple of days and again
revelations in the papers this morning
that the the remit uh the the width with
which sue gray has cast her net has
expanded and that can only be a bad
thing for those she's investigating
yeah indeed and it does make you wonder
um just how much she has been told in
her various investigations if she's
learning things from the press as well
and therefore continuing her
investigations and this is dangerous
because the longer this is left there is
more scope for further revelations and
further pieces of evidence to come out
adding to this drip drip narrative that
we have seen uh around parties and
around other uh
other things that you know were
happening were told were happening that
should not have been happening and that
that does not bode well because uh mps
who have been wavering and perhaps after
last week gave the prime minister a bit
more time until the report was done
still need convincing and still need to
be shown that they made you know they
have a decision to make post post that
report coming out and um i i think it
still feels relatively feeble
yeah i mean as is so often the case with
the sunday papers it's the it's the
detail that emerges and the margins of
the story not necessarily on the on the
front page which is perhaps most
revealing the the idea that the prime
minister has found himself in such a
sticky wicket that he's had to set up
his own shadow whipping operation
doesn't speak of a
of a man in command of his party
no
definitely not i think the authority has
been draining away
for a while and now certainly in number
10 behind the scenes there will be a lot
of focus on attempting to limit the
damage almost trying to prepare for what
this report will say does is everything
included is everything out there is
there scope for other things to be
revealed uh either in the report will be
damagingly or even more damagingly after
the report has been published what if
there's another big revelation that
hasn't been covered at all uh there'll
be an focus on party management as well
as you alluded to uh it seems that the
prime minister is getting ready to put
up a fight in any potential vote in
their confidence this involves
identifying which mps might be wavering
which which mps need a lot more
convincing and what can be done to bring
them around and then we focus on the
bigger picture you've heard a lot uh in
the last few days of some mps being a
bit more visible to come and defend the
prime minister and suddenly the
narrative has shifted from not just
let's wait for the su grey report but
talking about the bigger calls that they
say he has got right on vaccination on
uh perhaps not going into stronger
lockdown measures so there's a lot of
work going on behind the scenes but
whether it will be enough uh is i think
the big question here well that's the
big question i'm going to ask you to
answer more um and you from your
perspective can he do it can he recover
this one
i i'm not i'm not sure that he can
because i think the a lot of the damage
has already been done in terms of trust
and authority eroding mps will still be
getting a lot of heat from their
constituents
in terms of different rules for
different people and it seems clear that
this report
which is you know now extremely kind of
famous and looked forward to the fact
that it's taking so long it does feel
that there is much more there and
there's much more to to go through and
you know that may well be revealed which
will add further to the damage and then
if you look at things like uh local
elections coming up in may other
challenges that the country and the
government is facing i think a lot of
these uh issues will be on the minds of
mps and it seems to me that the
threshold at least for a version of
confidence will be reached uh
you know not maybe imminently but quite
soon
well we will soon see uh mo hussein
great to have you on the program this
morning really appreciate your time
thank you
now britain has accused russia of
plotting to install a pro-kremlin
government in kiev as moscow weighs up a
further invasion of ukraine
in an unusual move based on classified
intelligence the foreign office alleges
that a former ukrainian mp is being
considered as a potential candidate for
leader
what would be a significant escalation
of the crisis our defense and security
editor deborah haynes reports
it's not just russia's overt military
buildup around ukraine that's got
western allies worried
they suspect covert action as well
the uk accusing russia of plotting to
install a pro-kremlin leader to head the
government here in kiev
the foreign office claimed this former
ukrainian mp yevan miraev is being
considered as a potential candidate
his facebook page seemingly making light
of the allegation
in a rare release of classified
information the uk also alleged other
former ukrainian politicians are in
contact with russian spies involved in
planning for an attack on ukraine
the foreign secretary liz trust said the
information being released today shines
a light on the extent of russian
activity designed to subvert ukraine and
is an insight into kremlin thinking
russia must de-escalate end its
campaigns of aggression and
disinformation and pursue a path of
diplomacy
as the uk and our partners have said
repeatedly any russian military
incursion into ukraine would be a
massive strategic mistake with severe
costs
britain's spy agencies are better known
for keeping secrets than making a splash
but at a time when information is being
used as a tool by either side to attack
the other it's perhaps not surprising
the uk has effectively gone on the
offensive
i think it's uh it's a very unusual
thing for the foreign officers to do and
no doubt it's based on uh intelligence
gathering
at the highest level
but i think it's a useful
thing to do because what it demonstrates
to russia very clearly
is that we know their intent we are in
no doubt at all as to what they're
trying to achieve
and that
we will expose them at every turn
and i think that's a very useful lesson
for russia to know
the kremlin denied the british
allegations accusing the uk of peddling
fake news
but this crisis is real and the stakes
are high
so high that the head of germany's navy
pictured here in delhi chose to resign
this weekend over comments he made about
president putin and crimea that
contradicted his nato allies it is easy
to even give him the respect he he
really demands and probably also
deserves
russia is an old country russia is an
important country the crimea peninsula
is gone they've never come back this is
it this is effect
on the ground new shipments of u.s
weapons to bolster ukraine's defenses
are evidence that weeks of diplomacy
have done little to diffuse tensions
neither side letting up on the pressure
debra haynes sky news
police in thailand are questioning a
local man after a british tourist was
killed and another injured in a knife
attack the incident took place in the
early hours of saturday in a town just
west of bangkok sky's southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins sent this
update
we've spoken to police in kanchanaburi
who are carrying out this investigation
they've told us that a 49 year old
british man has died and a 55 year old
british man is in hospital following
this attack they said they believe it
happened around 2 45 in the morning on
saturday morning outside a house which
is thought to belong to the victim's
girlfriend now they have told us that
they have arrested and are questioning a
man in his 20s a local man he's also
being offered psychiatric support and
you can see from pictures of the scene
that a sickle shaped
knife was found at the scene now the 55
year old britain who has survived is
said to have had an operation on
injuries to his head and his collarbone
area police have told us he's now in a
stable condition and they've said that
they are investigating lines of inquiry
with witnesses saying they heard a lot
of noise coming from the house
potentially loud music so they're
investigating allegations that perhaps
the man that they're questioning went to
the house in response to the music in
the middle of the night those
investigations are continuing we are
expecting an update from the police at
some point this afternoon but the
foreign office has said that they are
supporting thai police in this and
they've issued a statement saying we're
in contact with royal thai police
following the death of one british man
and the hospitalization of another in
thailand and are ready to provide
consular support
joanne robbins there now let's head to
tonga where the island's residents are
continuing to grapple with the aftermath
of a powerful tsunami that caused
widespread destruction this guy's greg
milan has been hearing from the aid
workers determined to help the community
recover
well the pace of that aid getting into
tonga is continuing to ramp up there
were three flights from australia that
landed on
saturday more supplies arriving from new
zealand and japan and of course that
royal navy warship due to join the
effort in the next few days
as well the the cleanup operation on the
ground is said to be going pretty
smoothly the communications are finally
slowly being
re-established the big concern is the
supply of clean drinking water and that
is a real focus for the the teams that
are there we've managed to get some
insight from the red cross team that's
been working on the ground in tonga for
a week now helping and supporting and
getting supplies to
people in need they've been part of that
clean up operation as well and what they
say is that the hardest hit have been
the people who were living on the most
remote islands who were forced to leave
because most of the buildings were
destroyed and have have left what have
been homes for generations to be in
shelters on on the main island and that
for everyone they say has taken a huge
emotional toll
talking with the families the stories
that they've been shared with me
like they witnessed they saw the waves
like instead of running they want to
witness first what's coming out from the
sea and then they start running and then
after what happened they came back to
their house and then the house will
be washed away i think for these
families what they witness uh they will
never forget and same even for myself um
what they shared with me um it really
stuck in my mind and then i wish somehow
that um
what red cross will do will help them
will support them
well the red cross team do say that
their supplies are running low in tonga
the u.n has said that there simply
aren't enough supplies on the ground so
those aid shipments are really essential
and the pace of those uh really needs to
increase they say that people are
overwhelmed in tonga by what they've
been through in the last week but
everyone says they're seeing a spirit
there a real desire
from the people of tonga to rebuild even
in the depths of what they've been
through in the last week
some of the morning's other news now and
hong kong's leader carrie lam has warned
that covert 19 infections could be
growing exponentially in a congested
area of the city
due to an outbreak in pet hamsters
earlier this week authorities ordered a
hamster cull
following the outbreak muslims urged
hong kongers to avoid gatherings ahead
of next week's lunar new year as the
region copes with the spread of the
omicron variant
let's turn our attention to skiing
because one british skier has made just
a little slice of history dave ryding
has become the first british competitor
ever to win a gold medal at the
prestigious alpine world cup in austria
after winning the men's slalom event the
35 year old is now also the oldest
winner of a men's world cup slalom
my first podium was here
you know i'm 35 so i didn't know if i
could keep going and do this so
to do it at this age was not easy but
thanks to my team they kept pushing me
more than i often want but uh
yeah means the world
and all this is bookings for ski
holidays are on the rise let's speak now
to steve ricketts managing director at
the british alpine ski school he joins
us live
from the french alps great to see you i
can just about see you i think the sun's
not quite risen there
just yet good to have you on the program
this morning and look we can we start
you know it's not the topic that we
booked you to speak on this morning but
i'm sure you will have a view steve on
that fantastic success a british skier
winning a gold medal at the alpine world
cup it's fantastic isn't it
absolutely unbelievable i have to send a
massive congratulations to dave riding
it's hard for brits to understand but
this is like a grand slam event he's the
first ever to win uh a world cup uh
event the first brit ever to win a world
cup event and we're all absolutely over
the moon and just before the olympics so
come on dave give us something to watch
in the olympics for the first time
that's all i can say
we will keep we will have to keep our
fingers crossed won't we um but just
tell us just a little bit then about how
things have been for you of course the
french have relaxed all the covert
restrictions that have i presume uh you
know paid to large swathes of your
business over the past couple of years
are things starting to pick up now
yeah like you say it's been it's been a
couple of years and we were we were very
hopeful for this season and there were
some uh difficult times through december
but yes it's all turned around now now
that the borders are open uh we're
welcoming people back uh we survived
over the december period with different
markets so brits couldn't come but uh
english-speaking tourists were coming
from places like australia uh we even
had russians uh lots of irish coming out
there so
the ski industry continued uh marginally
for that time but now people uh are more
enthusiastic they're starting to book
they're looking forward to the half term
into the easter period uh so we're
seeing a real influx in bookings we've
managed to go ahead with our training
instructor program which hasn't happened
for two years so we're so excited about
that that's our future uh new
instructors coming into the industry and
you guys and uh we're looking forward to
them having an industry to come to
i i do wonder steve just just how bad
did things get for you and your business
um at those points where you weren't
lucky enough to be able to see people
traveling in any kind of numbers to the
resort
it was a tough time and we are you know
we're a group of individuals and people
survived and the community helped each
other but we were literally shut down
for uh for a whole year so 18 months of
no trading whatsoever uh people having
to find other jobs at a time where it's
difficult to find jobs but everybody
pulled together and made it through to
now and we're really hopeful uh we've
been throwing a lifeline for this year
uh and hopefully because we're on the
downward slide of the kobe uh the
coveted peak we're hoping that it will
continue until sort of mid april end of
april uh and allow us to to catch up on
some of that trade and survive until
next year well we keep our fingers
crossed that that is certainly the case
and i do want to ask though of course
not every restriction has been removed
there is still a requirement to show a
negative test uh to show that the
vaccination is up to date has that
deterred
some of your potential client base
it doesn't because for the vaccinated
it's not like difficult you've got to
show a negative test but if you're fully
vaccinated uh you're welcome into the
country and that doesn't need to be uh a
booster vaccination if it's six months
it's your last uh vaccine the one
difficulty we have had is uh 12 to 17
year old children is that in the uk not
many of those were double vaccinated and
they were expected to be double
vaccinated to come to france
uh and participate in the same way
so we've got around that uh children are
having vaccinations sorry children are
testing either 12 to 50 years old they
don't have double vaccinations children
have been testing every 24 hours and
that's been allowing them to use the ski
slopes and the restaurants and
the facilities in resorts
apple steve wishing you all the very
best for the remainder of the season
that says steve ricketts speaking to us
from a beautiful beautiful part of the
french thanks for joining us thank you
have a great day you too with us once
again to review the papers the
broadcasters thomas copeland and after
adam guys lovely to see you again um
thomas to you first at the sunday
telegraph a story that i think
it has been resonating certainly over
the past couple of days that this
vaccine deadline for for nh nhs staff
might just be pushed back
that's right there's some plans within
number 10 that the uh that vaccine
deadline might be extended for six
months put on the shelf it's just two
weeks until the nhs is due to start
stacking staff who haven't been jabbed
haven't had their two jobs that policy
might not go by the wayside as boris
johnson tries to throw some policy
concessions to his back bench mps as
things stand all nhs staff have to have
both jobs by april the first but at the
moment up to 80 000 nhs staff that's
around six percent of the total
workforce haven't met those conditions
so at the moment there's some plans it's
a complicated way of doing it i suppose
but the suggestion is that they might
actually increase at the number of jobs
so you need to get your first second and
booster job and then put it six months
down the line and then that might just
be enough for tory mps backbench mps to
believe and the hope is that then by six
months down the line as the pandemic
starts to ease that actually you know
the idea might disappear entirely and
might not be needed at all so
the question i suppose for the
government's got to think for is what's
the value of throwing that policy
concession what's the value of seeing
through this deadline as well the
overall number of people vaccinated in
the population is about
85
with it in the nhs then that that goes
all the way up to 94 so you've got a
higher you know and the nhs is a really
large proportion it's a huge workforce a
massive organization so fairly
representative of the work of the
overall population if you actually see
through this deadline and start sacking
staff
will a number of them will those
percentages decrease will a number of
them then get the job the question is i
don't know
the overall point though these are
decisions that need to be taken with
that ethical and scientific reasoning
not just to throw a policy concession to
backbench mps in order to show up boris
johnson's leadership
um
yeah a change of pace here i i think
it's fair to say that neither the sunday
expression or its readership are known
for their republican tendencies on that
basis a poll carried in that paper
showing 72 percent want prince andrew
stripped of his dukedom i mean that will
be worrying for those at buckhouse
yes i think it will it shows that um you
know the tide is turning against prince
andrew now we know he's already been
stripped of his use of his royal
highness and several i mean all of his
military titles in fact by the queen and
that's over the civil lawsuit that he
faces in the u.s over allegations of
sexual assault and those are being made
by virginia dufrey
he has denied all these allegations and
will continue to deny them
when that comes to trial we think in the
autumn
uh but yes public opinion does seem to
be turning against them um
around three-quarters of people in this
poll thought that he should be stripped
of the use of the duke of york and also
lots of people thought that he should
also lose his place um in line to the
throne so he's ninth in line to the
throne at the moment and and 76 of
people thought that he should lose this
place in line to the throne so like i
said public opinion turning against
prince andrew as he faces that civil
lawsuit in the u.s of uh allegations of
sexual assault
made against him by virginia dufresne
that could be very very damaging if you
have public details you know made public
of what happened between the two of them
in court and of course you must say that
he denies all the allegations
um thomas let's talk tax rises and of
course that that national insurance
height the rishi sunac announced quite
some time ago of 1.25 percentage points
from april i don't know about you but to
me it's always looked like it was
hanging on something of a sugarly peck
uh certainly blue uh blue tories are
calling on at blue collar tories are
calling on rishi soon not to think again
that's right it's reported here in the
sun it's also on the front page of the
daily telegraph as well robert generic
former housing minister a fairly
significant intervention saying he's
against this proposed right it was it's
one of the most popular demands of the
moment by backbenchtory mps trying to
squeeze something out of the government
at a time when the leadership is is in
dire straits and this it's a 1.25 rise
it's meant to come in around the april
and for three years that's ring fenced
and that's meant to be
the health and social care levy and the
problem is it's kicking in april i think
april 1st in and around the time when
you've also got huge rises in energy and
council tax bills national insurance
just by itself for a worker on 30 grand
a year is meant to take a 255 pound or
so hit so
you're moving in a position where you've
got a very unpopular prime minister
during a cost of living crisis uh so
it's no wonder that the government is
considered considering giving in on this
i suppose the problem is off the back of
the pandemic and the social and health
care service that's already in a very
difficult position it needs to be paid
for somehow so a great many tory mps
certainly are against an increase in
national insurance contributions but if
it's not that what else is it going to
be is it going to be asking older and
wealthier folks maybe with houses to pay
more through wealth tax capital assets
it's likely that those are even less
popular decisions but again you know
these are decisions that need to be
approached rationally rather than just
you know as as a piece of red meat
through the back bench toward emps
i feel that let's stick with the the
cost of living crisis on the front of
the sunday people jack monroe someone i
interviewed actually
many many years ago and found them to be
incredibly impressive that their
experience of course of what it is like
to live on the bread line to to
literally be counting the pennies every
week before you go to the shop i will
they know lots about that
oh yeah stanford road does know a lot
about that they were in the sunday
people 10 years ago
talking about how they lived on 10
pounds a week with with their son and
and managed to feed themselves and you
know they talked about how um they would
miss meals actually and still on that 10
pounds a week just managing to feed
their son and so they revisited uh that
same shopping basket
that they uh bought all the stuff for 10
pounds now today it's costing 17 pounds
11. and jack monroe's point is about the
cost of living is rising and the real
impact of that you know we talk about
inflation and sort of abstract terms but
they really broke it down and i read on
twitter this week where they were
talking about what it really means and
when the cost of living goes up they
said they've had people contacting them
pensioners and saying that they put a
mouthful of toothpaste in their mouth
before they go to bed so they feel cool
that this pensioner was just drinking
pints and pints of water to keep full
and you know this um thread that i
actually read on twitter was really
fascinating because it breaks it down
into real times of how much more
expensive everything is um so she uh
they've said that the cheapest pasta in
a local supermarket uh with 29p for 500
grams that's 10 years ago now it's 70p
for 500 grams at cheapest rice was 45
fee for a kilogram now that's one pound
for 500 grams that's a 344 percent
increase at curry sauce with 30p now
it's 89p
196
increase so as we talk about energy
bills going up losing the universal
credit uplift it really breaks it down
in real time just how much more
expensive things are and the basket i
thought was most shocking what was 10
pounds worth of a basket 10 years ago
it's now 17 times 11. it is incredible
it is incredible thomas to finish us off
this hour um you often wonder which came
first the story or the headline on this
one i think it was probably the headline
which is con fishing tell us about the
story quickly
yeah you can always rely on the sun to
get a good headline it's young offenders
in yorkshire being given the opportunity
to have a good angling something i'm
really in favor of especially with young
offenders there's no point in throwing
people in prison and throwing away the
key the reality is especially with
younger offenders there will be
rehabilitation is key they will be back
out into society and it's initiatives
like this actually giving young people
an opportunity to try something
different and angling comes with all
sorts of skills patience resilience and
appreciation of nature those are the
kind of values we need to nurture as
young people go through a rehabilitation
process well done thomas both
professional broadcasters they are
mounted to cram in the stories into the
short amount of time after thomas lovely
to see you both this morning thanks very
much for joining us